hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to racketboy now this is the
number 1 gold winning first prize game
out of the game jolt game jam and there
was a lot of really cool ones I mean I
mean the top three are really great but
I plan to like play on my own through a
lot more of these loving memory of King
manatee will implement okay alright then
I'm ready to play
how do i how do I play oh there we go
woah oh woah oh okay oh it's like a
combo brick breaker shmup it's a it's a
British pub it's a smut breaker
it's a shrew / worker why am i killing
these ducks and why are they shooting
fireballs out of their butts shall are
you worried about this in any way I mean
I want to be worried about a lot of
things but usually in my life it doesn't
really matter
okay oh I can't I can't reflect those
haha is niche that's what you get that's
that's what you all get okay so if I can
just keep my balls in play I'm never
gonna warn everybody oh my gosh I got a
buddy who's actually really crazy holy
crap does well made oh my god it's so
cool it's so cool why is it so cool oh
man I know why this one one first plate
I was thinking like sushi dough when I
was playing it just like a few seconds
ago it was really well made and really
fun I didn't know how it's gonna be
beaten but goddamn this this is cool
okay cool okay I would like to get to
the next level now if I can just you
know get to get to the next area thank
you Oh Alan super bad I want to lose
that one whoop oh there we go
oh damn it come on you duck fireball
butt-blasting duck bastards get load of
my reflective properties of Moroccan
okay I seem to have oh god damn it
I can use with some well nevermind then
I'm just gonna go on my way Oh didn't
help me at all I feel completely and
utterly okay so it's like it's not like
normal brick breakers where if you get
him behind them they do good and stuff
god damn my my ad D is going off ten
million times a second Jesus
someone things colors Jesus okay I'm
just gonna let him pass because that's
when they go okay goodbye I said goodbye
good day sir no oh damn it that's my
buddy my buddies are helping me out of
your question mark damn it god I'm bad
at this I'm bad at this bad at this
there we go I want to keep that one
keeping this one damn it damn it oh
there we go that's the stuff that's the
stuff baby oh god damn it this is tough
it's tough
oh god damn it well that's not helpful
Oh cry man was really interesting I mean
there's not much that I can say about
the game itself it's obviously a very
basic shmup and obviously I'm not gonna
do a full playthrough but there's
definitely something that you guys
should check out if you're interested in
this rather absurd mix him up of genres
like I saw this other game that was um
it was it was uh was ACOG pong
pac-man and space invaders all wrapped
in one game it was really cool by the
way it was like totally I mean it made
sense and it was like had the little bit
of futuristic styling while still
retaining a lot of the like old style
graphics of the of the day I don't know
if I can describe that perfectly right
now but I mean like if you see the game
you'll see what I mean because the game
was really really like really sharp and
snazzy and that's the only words that I
can describe right now because my
vocabulary is being tested because all
my brain power is being diverted to
looking at the pretty colors
oh my god pretty cars okay duck shooting
bastard get out of here donut
scowling piece of
there we go that's more like it got you
okay
come on you there we go
oh I'll take that big racket oh my god
that's so much better
that's so much better oh I love that can
I keep that forever as long as I don't
get hit right probably oh it's gone
goddamnit I thought well this is fun
nevermind please leave thank you I'm an
idiot I die too soon that's more like it
or not
damnit God my one thing yes son of a
what is rocky in the face how about that
I'm actually curious so these levels
gonna get any more complex or is this
like the limit of what its gonna be
oh that hurts me too damn it
come on you I'm open there's gonna
be a boss stage pretty soon cuz I mean
there's got to be an end of the game
other than just me dying right well
probably not that didn't have to be
come on okay I'm getting better
reflecting them well I mean I say that
now look watch as I miss every single
one of her gear up
dubs yep that's me miss and that's a
whole lot of me miss and that's that's
diet yeah there you go
okay all right
oh my god my eyes are hurting there's so
many things to keep track of oh my god
okay there we go there we go there we go
there we go oh boy buh buh buh buh buh
buh Oh what is it going are you okay
over there you okay buddy oh no no no no
no no there we go
prop ah such a tool come on you oh
what's that
was that a fisting Fister don't drift me
faster don't do it no okay there we go
I'll get through getting the gap getting
that thread the needle brother Neil get
in the hole get in the hole get in the
goddamn hole there we go okay you're
thanksfully the duck ass blasting
bastards are still around - give me you
feed me cuz I'm so terrible babies Rick
I can't words right now I can't I can't
words most of the time but it really
can't words right now oh my god it's so
much concentration I have a concentrated
this heart sounds nice cool Oh God well
Who am I kidding I never concert in high
school
it's okay come on you oh well how do we
bad in the real world
I should just not go outside because I
have is to get for a green ass blasting
bastard duck
you don't shoot any balls I would rather
have balls please thank you
jet ski oh god the duck is
aiming at me that's what it's doing now
I was wondering what was different about
it oh man it's like the brain the main
brain power that I'm having to do is
having to predict where everything's
going all at the same time oh god it's
getting crowded in here because I have
to I have to like I have to keep track
of everything and then I also have to
use brain power to try to calculate
where the hell it's gonna be multi-ball
Ferrari have multi balls what do you
mean multi ball there's nothing but
multi balls oh okay ooh boy Oh Nellie
Oh Nellie come on Nellie oh I got
it get dead yes didn't better getting
better and getting better at in better
Oh God bull testicles huh she knows and
watching my back oh man well there I go
game over okay so technically I don't
know which one's better between this and
sushi dough
sushi go I have no idea but this one was
really good anyway like it's really
close between the two this one's fun and
it tooks up so much of your mind trying
to keep track of everything but it's
really cool so you can play this one try
to beat my high score it probably won't
be all that hard because I'm very stupid
so thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the other cool games
that I've done there's a huge playlist
over 100 videos old and new thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video
i oh yeah before I go let me know which
one you like best of Supernanny
sushi dough and racketboy let me know
which one you like best because there
were 1 2 3 in the game gold gin game
Joel game Dave go to go bye wow they're
actually just body parts now by texting
you - laughs I don't giggle